the strong gets more
[Music]
while the weak ones fade
empty pockets don't
ever make the grace i found out about
that week from harry belafonte
i went over to his home and all of a
sudden effortlessly
he started talking about this week of
television and the tonight show i'm
thinking
wait a minute harry belafonte hosted a
week of the tonight show
what what how did i not know this that
was probably
the most revolutionary move
that mainstream television could have
done at the time
[Music]
i write about tv i write about politics
i should have known about it why is this
history lost to us
that's right harry belafonte takes an
existing
white institution in american culture
and he turns it into something that
represents
his world that it should be
multicultural that it should be
politically engaged
what harry belafonte did he combined
politics and entertainment it was like a
forerunner to the daily show
and the stephen colbert show is that a
fancy way of saying
i told you so
i mean this is early 1968 the nation was
really in
crazy upheaval there was increasing
and very appropriate black anger
and harry exposed you as a white person
speaking as a white person
to this vibrant world where black people
and white people
met as equals this was a talented
intelligent sophisticated passionate
social activist of a black man in that
chair
that has through the years been the seat
of white males
my parents allowed me to stay up late
they said
you need to see this it was something
that was really inspiring especially to
a lot of black people who were watching
who had not seen themselves necessarily
represented in that way
in that american institution that is the
tonight show harry belafonte
at 11 o'clock late night was saying
we're here we're americans
we're part of this we're not going
anywhere y'all brought us now we're here
so get in your bed let me be the last
thing you see before you go to sleep
mr belafonte would you like to look at
your guest list from that week
love to see
you